a man being found guilty of murdering a
police custody sergeant in Croydon in
2020 Matt Ratner was shot dead by 25
year old uh Louis 23 year old Luis De
soyuza in the holding room at the police
custody Center this is a police
body-worn footage of De soyuza being
stopped in search in London South London
in the early hours of the 25th of
September of 2020 he was arrested
initially for possession of drugs and
ammunition ammunitions and bullets that
were found he was also carrying cannabis
seven rounds of ammunition but officers
failed to find a loaded revolver that
was in a holster
I'd like to warn you that what we're
about to show now in the moments leading
up to the shooting of Sergeant Ratner
you may find disturbing so do look away
if you do in this later footage here
Sergeant Ratner enters across study
Suite to talk to de zoyser
then does still handcuffed fires the
weapon and Mr Ratner falls to the ground
so the two other officers immediately
attempt to restrain to soyuza but three
further shots are fired
I think The Bravery of those two
officers at that point in time is
something that
none of us can ever quite put ourselves
in that position I know having spoken to
them the thoughts
about the consequences of they not
having family far on on the street
itself but going back to search there's
always again at the police station is
something which I'm sure will never
leave them never leave them this is a
this is a tragedy that
will never will never disappear for
Matt's partner Sue and his family and of
course the impact on my colleagues both
officers and and staff is um is
something that I'm sure will be with
them throughout not just their
professional lives but also their
personal lives